dan dan dan dan tank wonder sound test
this is a sound test oh this is the
sound test hey guys welcome back to the
Evan and Kaitlyn podcast today we're
gonna be talking about what's new we're
gonna be talking about burnout we will
have an AB outline don't really like so
you know what usually when people are
like saying what the podcast is gonna be
about they say it in a way that like
makes people listen then there'll be an
AB hey people can get excited that this
podcast is financially supporting this
I'm also talking about like we're gonna
say what's new with us then we'll have a
topic then an ad and then we'll play a
game no I said what the topic is oh you
did I said burn out ok I was too
distracted okay guys today we're gonna
talk about the secret truth behind the
try guys legends of the internet tour
shocking emotional the secret truth of
youtuber burnout emotional secrets
Squarespace ad and the secrets of our
relationship the secrets of a
relationship in the form of a couple's
game and then the secret things that we
haven't been obsessing with past week
everything is a secret are you guys
intrigues now vote below which which
intro is better
probably Caitlyn's intriguing secret one
gosh well I think the interesting thing
about the try guys legends of the
internet tour that we attended it was
really interesting because that was the
first event that we've ever been to of
that type yeah well in a little
background if you didn't hear us talk
about it on the last podcast podcast
the podcast try guys is a channel that
we really really like we've been
watching them for a long time and even
since before they had their own channel
they it used to be with BuzzFeed um and
they recently started going on tour and
at first we were like I didn't really
know what the tour was no clue what it
would be I kind of did a little bit like
I they gave a teaser of it on one of
their podcasts and I listened to it I'm
like we have to go Caitlin didn't want
to listen to it because she wanted to be
a surprise yeah yeah but the reason well
at that point we decided we were gonna
go this Neely it made me want to go is
cuz they did an episode with some of the
behind the scenes from yeah yeah but
anyway so the the tour was a mixture of
like there was some stand-up there were
musical numbers there's all the audience
on stage yeah a lot of interactive stuff
chicken at us and we all ate it together
yeah really through chicken strips into
the audience
Raising Cane's there was like some
improv type stuff oh oh I want to tell
the story of the Pokemon but we'll get
that later we should fully describe what
that what it was first and then we can
describe done okay I mean do you want to
say war yeah I think it was just really
cool because they got their start on
BuzzFeed doing kind of like the we try
on funny like outfits then they've kind
of continued to like work on their
branding and kind of developed their own
like feel and style and like what their
brand is and there's really interesting
to see that translate to and onstage
performance because it felt very much
like them but like so much more - it was
interesting because it was like polished
in a good way but also unpolished in a
good way
yeah does that make sense like it was
very professional but at the same time
you know chicken nuggets every have the
YouTube first thing they had some
secrets and behind-the-scenes thing this
it was it was really interesting a lot
of what we're saying probably won't make
sense if you don't watch there
and if you haven't been to the show so
I'm trying not to alight yeah I get into
the specific go into too many of the
specifics but I think the overall thing
was well one it was awesome
- I think like you're like you touched
on earlier it was really cool to see a
YouTube channel on tour yes not that
that's I don't think that's something
that we would do it doesn't like work
with our channels no but I just thought
it was super interesting to see it was
like going to a concert there were
bouncers there were merch table this
more than any concert I've been to more
than any play that I've been do this
because I laughed so much and there was
music there was dancing there was comedy
there's interaction it was like a mix of
like a stand-up a concert and a YouTube
video because there's so much
audio-visual going on there's a game
show that happened on stage with
audience member I wonder if this is like
because they come from the YouTube space
where like everyone's fighting for
attention you know you have to like keep
the pacing right and you have to not
waste people's time I feel like every
moment of their performance was used
very well and I was super engaged the
whole time you know what I mean
which I mean I haven't been to a ton of
like plays and stuff this time zone out
a little plays I definitely don't out
even Archimedean sometimes all Zona yeah
now there are some I think the second
best concert I've ever been to or like
experience I've been to was SIA Oh coz
it was amazing but it was because of the
like performance it was because of the
performance yeah the performance 100%
the reason why I was like whoa like that
the dance the light the audiovisual
thing going on in the way I mean all
concerts have like dancing and lights
and audio-visual oh my god the level of
SIA it was like a weird artsy like
interpretive experience it was it was
cool okay so the try guys have done the
series before where they they wrote
their own fanfiction well no no they
found
it started where they found me they
found a fanfiction and then they
replaced all of the found a fanfiction
they decided to make a video about like
based on the fanfiction because it was
too raunchy they replaced in Iran G
words with sandwiches yeah so any
raunchy words were replaced with
pastrami or yeah sandwich related term
innuendos were like sandwich related so
they wanted to do that again live on
stage so they had a general script but
with um they rewrote or they wrote a
like chapter 2 yeah chapter 2 of that
same story I needed an audience
suggestion of what the raunchy words
would be replaced with so I yelled out
Pokemon and the people around us started
chanting out Pokemon too and we got them
to do a raunchy fanfiction where all the
wrong keywords were replaced by Pokemon
names and it was it was the best thing
I've seen yeah that was my favorite part
I don't know if I'm biased because they
picked like ours our work also is so
great do because I know that like half
the people in the audience were like
what anyone who didn't know a Pokemon
and Pokemon terms I feel like most
people know oh yeah is that audience
probably everyone knew with the pool
yeah it's like that it's also fun cuz
they were like like what's that tall guy
says Pokemon now if we ever get to meet
them we're gonna be like hey you're the
tall guy Pokemon at a Houston show that
was us that doesn't sound creepy at all
[Laughter]
yeah it was super fun yeah alright
moving on to the main topic this this
was kind of inspired you know we Kahlan
and I have talked about burnout quite a
lot behind the scenes but this topic in
particular today was inspired because a
few people that we kind of follow or
we've kind of seen some more stories pop
up about it around um overly attached
girlfriend she had a YouTube channel she
was like me she's got her internet start
as a meme she turned that in
YouTube channel like way back in the day
like 2011 or yeah I think yeah don't
think it was like battle okay
well fairly early on in the YouTube
space and she kind of turned that into a
little bit of a youtube career but she
just just posted a video saying like I
quit and this is the end of my channel
and then philip defranco talked about
burnout recently - on one of his second
channels that he's starting up so it
kind of like re-entered our minds and
this kind of an interesting thing to
talk about because part of our strategy
like you know we've kind of grown in
different phases you know initially we
were just in the scrappy phase and then
we are like ramping up to like somewhat
legitimacy and I feel like we're past
the legitimacy stage I think we are
legit the main thing we're trying to
figure out now is how to make this as
sustainable as possible so we don't
approach that burnout and I think that's
been the focus of the past year yeah so
when they say like we talk about burnout
a lot it's not because like we are burnt
out it's because we are thinking ahead
and we see people burning out and we're
like okay what what things can we do now
to avoid that because if we didn't take
those steps we would probably be like oh
yeah we work a lot there are some weeks
where I note or we've noted if we did
this again and again and again
we totally burn out but like we try to
be very conscious of it and take steps
to avoid it when we can like avoid those
types of weeks when we came and we can't
always sometimes we get ourselves in a
situation with like a deadline or
whatever and like it's just one of those
weeks yeah oftentimes like sponsors or
projects scope like get in the way of
our plans not to burn out we're not to
work at the level that would lead to
burnout yes but you know we always like
self balance and everything but anyways
so I watched both of the videos I don't
think you watch to you I did not watch
either but you know what I did do what's
that
I read the reddit comments I overly
attached girlfriend okay so I I can talk
about the video you can talk about the
comments because there's two different
perspectives yeah so um the overly
attached girlfriend story she
got her start when YouTube wasn't that
legit of a career at all not many people
were doing that full-time and she tried
to make a go of it but I think it was
especially easy to get lost back then
because there weren't sponsors to rely
on there weren't like patreon there
wasn't all of these ways to turn this
into a career was there absent there's
Adsense
I think there's ad sense but I'm not
sure how good it was for individual
channels I think multi-channel networks
could get better deals and stuff but I
think it was especially hard for
individual individuals because I know I
know that I've heard some channels talk
about that back in the day it was kind
of worse worse in a lot of ways better
in some but worse in a lot of ways
so when when I if I thought of starting
a career back then in YouTube I would be
incredibly freaked out too it's like
like if I put years into this career
path in air quotes and then I want to go
back to a normal job what if I have six
years on my resume of like youtuber and
back then that was so much less legit
you know like I think that if we not
that we're gonna do this but if we
worked in YouTube content production for
six years and we decided we want to
retire we could move to be consultants
for a big company we could start our own
agency we could do like a bajillion
things with the skills that we've picked
up and they're all really marketable
things now but I think back then like
the the stress of making YouTube work
the stress of all the unknown there's
more pressure on it because if you
didn't make it work or well I guess hmm
I'm gonna rephrase that maybe more
stress on it because like making it work
was less of a common thing yeah with the
ability to make it work wasn't there
weren't people being full-time youtubers
left and right Ben I think I think
that's part of it and I think that
because of all of that pressure because
of all of that unknowns there's a big
mismatch in the content that she was
putting out and the behind-the-scenes
and that contrast really got or her and
made her seriously depressed because in
her videos they worked best when she was
happy and positive and she wanted to be
that putting that out into the world
that's the content that she wanted to
make
and then afterwards should be like okay
I think I got another good video now
it's time to edit it let's have a
breakdown because I don't know what I'm
doing next week let's figure this out I
don't know how I'm gonna pay the bills
like I don't know all these thing is
there's this huge mismatch between her
on-screen moments and her off-screen
moments and that kind of put her in a
bad place and that like kind of
snowballed in a way over time until it
just wasn't a positive thing anymore and
she just couldn't do it because that
also like you know for us to if we're in
a bad mood we don't film because it
won't lead a good content and it's it's
not easy to like pretend like you're in
a good mood by not easy
kaylynn saying that evan can't do it i
literally can't I remember once this is
kind of a different situation but it was
like um 2017 so when we had first
started our channel and it was around
the holidays and we we already had some
like sponsor deals and it was some of
our early sponsor deal so it was like
even more yeah to do well with some of
our first sponsors and we had a holiday
related video it was like ornaments
video and so it had to be out before
Christmas in our brains it was like
super high priority it was with for
sponsor and we had orders back then we
were doing West Elm order and we were
still doing West West Elm orders which
were extra crazy on the holidays anyways
I was sick I had like 100 200 3 degree
fever like a pretty high fever during
all of the filming of that ornaments
video yeah and trying to like be on was
so difficult and it was interesting
because when I mean the video didn't
even it's still one of our lowest
performing videos even like at the time
it was a low performer at Just Cause
like our videos get more views now than
they did then and I remember thinking
like like was it worth pushing myself
and like probably getting sicker and
like struggling through this video in it
you know didn't even do that well and an
interesting contrast is when we did the
this the desk we're sitting at now our
progress car rainbow resin desk there
was like that's
banned a longer time period and I
remember one of those days like I wasn't
feeling super great or like I didn't
sleep well I forgot what it was but I
wasn't feeling super great and at first
I was trying to do the same thing kind
of like put on a happy face and pretend
like I remember this and I was
struggling oh yeah and we even included
some of the takes that failed yeah so
then I was like you know what whatever
I'm just gonna admit that I'm not
feeling great my brains not working and
like it ended up being a good moment a
good I feel like a good part of the
video cuz I was like struggling with my
words and like you know you're kind of
teasing me in a fun way and I was making
fun of myself and it just like worked
much better kind of acknowledging and
being 100% real and real and like that
made it easier to kind of be in a good
mood because I was like okay I don't
have to worry about like saying this
line perfectly cuz it's like I'm sick
whatever you guys know what I'm saying
yeah but I can see that's a little
different than like middle of a video
just saying you know what I'm depressed
that's all let's get through the rest of
this video guys that is a little harder
but I do feel like I've heard you know
there have been other youtubers that
talked about you know the struggle of
like trying to be on on-camera but
really like not being happy off camera
yeah it's also tough because I think
that you know being a successful content
creator is a desirable position so when
you're upset or when you're in a bad
place and you're in this position it's
hard to kind of share that it's hard to
express that it's hard to like if you
don't have someone behind the scenes to
say look this is hard and you know we're
still lucky we're still very happy but
this moment is a hard moment if you
don't have that ability behind the
scenes and for someone to fully
understand it I think it could be really
hard yeah well because well it's hard to
like be honest about it too on your
channel because then you feel like
you're complaining yeah you know and
it's hard to complain from like a lucky
position because we are really lucky and
we feel very grateful to be doing what
we're doing and it also seems like like
the bigger and more successful your
channel isn't the longer you been doing
you can complain the less you can
complain but also like
I feel like the more prone you are to
feeling that stress and getting
depressed about things you know um cuz
if you try it for a year and you're like
oh that's not for me
it's the stakes aren't as high almost
yeah you know I think there's another
interesting phenomenon that we
discovered in I have the beginning of
this year our channel started doing
better and better and better and we were
experiencing all this growth and while
it was really exciting and we really
appreciate all of the growth we have
seen and all of that at the same time
what was really interesting is the
pressure kind of started to build you
know it's like each video did really
good and instead of like saying like
okay we've had all this growth it's okay
if the next one flops it's like we
almost have felt more pressure to make
the next one do even better yeah because
you don't know like break your streak
you don't break your streak you don't
like drop the ball you know yeah so it's
kind of like with with success comes
almost more pressure yeah that's
interesting because when we are thinking
of ideas I think like one of our videos
the desk was going like really big and
viral and we are considering what video
to make after and we went through a lot
of ideas because no we can't do that we
can't do that that one's a little bit
risky that's unknown we don't want to
like throw a risky video right out of
this desk yeah yeah I think like we've
evened out a little bit now because like
the we've been in a more consistent
growth rate than when we like first
started growing significantly faster
than we had before the beginning of this
year it's kind of like held relatively
steady and so now it doesn't seem like a
temporary fleeting thing yeah that's
like at the beginning of the growth
spurt it was like oh god like I don't
want to go back to we're a little bit
more secure yeah the interesting thing
about Philip defranco's video on oh yeah
I'm really curious about that one
because like overly attached girlfriend
I didn't really watch her channel but
like we watch decent amount of I think I
think I'm gonna try to take all I'll
summarize the takeaways that I got from
it
one he said that you know it's
especially hard for him to just keep on
cranking out all these videos just
sitting behind a desk without much like
interaction with the audience and and he
went in this video he went to an event
in Austin like roosterteeth Fest or
something or I don't know it sounds
really cool we should go next year cuz
it's in Austin really really close and
there's like cosplay there's comedy
there's events there's awesome there's
all this cool stuff anyways so he said
that like meeting people engaging with
them really gave him like a huge boost
and we've experienced stuff like that
too when we go to events I think one of
his strategies moving forward and I've
kind of seen it because he has his
Phillip DeFranco show he started the
rogue rocket which is like a just news
organization that isn't as reliant on
him and he's also starting like a
channel rate as does whatever he wants
to Franco does the Franco does and he
does like he's done interviews with his
wife and his kid he did like this video
that's kind of like explaining some of
his backstory and his thoughts I'm just
random things or YouTube life I think
that having those other creative escapes
adds that variety and makes you stay
like keeps you passionate about things
you know interesting yeah and I think
that that's something that we've kind of
that's a thought and strategy that we've
had and we've been working on for a
while with the podcast and with the
gaming channel mm-hmm it was another one
of those like it wasn't that we were
feeling burnout and then we were like oh
god we gotta do something to like mix it
up but it was like in order to avoid
future burnout let's this sounds weird
start more channel more to our workload
but things that are kind of like a
little bit less pressure yeah you know
like recording a podcast is a lot less
pressure than you know doing a full
project video doing a gaming video is a
lot less pressure than doing a full
project like especially is especially
evident in our intros that's one thing
that we've been kind of struggling with
they have recently been more and more of
a struggle for us in the past four
months yeah I think as we've continued
to shift
our strategy because in the beginning
hey guys revin Pilon and we are gonna do
X and we kind of show the end product
and then we get into it and we follow
that formula but our videos now we kind
of want to give people a heads up that
this is gonna be a fun video and it's
like we're making a thing we want you
know thing we're making but we also want
you to know that this is not a how-to
video this is an entertaining video
because setting expectations is a really
important part of videos and
entertainment I think yeah so like for
example I'll use this um the podcast us
the rainbow resin desk again if we had
done it in our past style like when we
were still doing more how-to videos it
would have been hey guys we're Evan in
Katelyn and today we're making a rainbow
resin streaming desk and then we show it
and we'd be with the final desk and
there would be some final shots of the
desk and then be like okay so first off
we're gonna do this
yes but instead we started this desk
with bad infomercials inappropriate skip
you know and that skit was so fun to
make it was super fun too and then we
started with like a side by side like
like time-lapse on one side and many
other side beyond the intro but also
that that continues like the
entertaining feel and stuff it's like
we're talking like we're talking about
my passion 40 solid aluminum framing
we're not talking about like so the
reason why we chose to use lot aluminum
framing is because x y&z no it's like
I'm obsessed with tea table maiming and
Caitlin indulges my obsession an
entirely different shift
yeah that's Jim but yeah so um you were
getting to something about the
difference between main channel the
gaming channel based on the interest
yeah so thank you for bringing so the
intros will sometimes take us five hours
to maybe not five hours but a long time
for our main channel because there's a
lot of pressure to get it right right at
the beginning and silly for them to take
so long and they don't always take know
sometimes they take an hour sometimes
they take but even that seems kind of
silly because you watch the videos and
the intro such a quick thing but I think
like you do if you if you do one or one
to three takes and you get it in the
first three it's like okay great that
could be a 15 minute process yeah but if
it goes
beyond that you start like getting in
your head about it yeah I mean and for
the podcast we've never had trouble with
an intro not really
and with the gaming we've never had
trouble with an intro so good so good I
think the gaming is a more a better
example though okay because it's like
the podcast is it different is this like
there's more differences in content type
but don't like I mean videos and the
podcast versus our main videos in the
gaming yeah because the gaming videos
are all still very edited and we do this
kind of like trust and editors that
there's something good in some of what
we recorded to use as an intro well no
we still do an intro oh yeah we do it we
do an intro we do introduce well but
it's cuz like we're streaming while
we're doing it and we know the editors
will make something good out of it and
we just like have faith of them we just
you know there's only one intro take and
it's not it doesn't even feel like it
take because we're talking to the chat
yeah the live chat kind of like saying
what we're gonna be playing today or
what our goals are for the game or
whatever and so it is kind of different
and it is much lower pressure just like
the stakes are a lot lower yeah you know
it's also really easy about evident
Caitlyn gaming creating a website for it
I've been feeling gaming calm when we
wanted to make a website for everything
Caitlyn gaming we use Squarespace
because we could use one of their
beautiful templates that's already like
pretty much done we just dropped some
content in there and Squarespace for our
podcast website yep yep and we already
know the system and we know that they
have reliable hosting and they have 24/7
support if we need any help so if you
like us need to make a website you can
head over to Squarespace com to start a
free trial and when you're interested
and sold by the wonderfulness of the
interface you can head over to
Squarespace calm / evident Caitlyn for
squarespace.com slash evident Caitlyn
podcast nice catch for for 10% off your
first purchase if you use code Evan and
Gilliam no I think there's no good okay
there's no code squarespace.com 7k lim
podcast don't listen to anything evan
said only listen to what I said okay
doctor um so just a little bit more I
think on burnout I think that you read
some reddit comments which were
interesting to you so one of the most
interesting things that I read and this
is you know with read it you just kind
of feel like some of the top comments
and I did go down a little bit but I
didn't think it too deep but it's always
interesting to me to see that the top
comments because those have the most up
vote so it's like those people agree
with that one of the most interesting
ones that I read and I don't necessarily
agree with it is that youtubers have
like like comparing youtubers to
traditional celebrities and how it's
like we have all of the hardships but
none of the perks and I'll explain what
they said oh so it's like you have the
struggles of like you're in the public
eye and you get public scrutiny and it's
a lot of pressure to always be on and
always do everything right and all that
but you don't get the you don't have the
support team of traditional celebrities
you're usually not making as much money
as traditional celebrities you don't
have the like respect of like your
creative work there's a lot of people
that look at anything on YouTube and
it's just like oh whatever you know
that's not actually like real videos so
there's like a difference in
expectations from the audience from you
know content creators and traditional
celebrities to you know it's like that's
true because like celebrities it's like
they're on this different level and so
there's no expectation for like a
celebrity to reply to your comment yeah
you know but if like a youtuber doesn't
you might be like oh yeah
again I don't necessarily agree with all
of that because I think that there are a
lot of perks of being a youtuber that
like you don't get as a celebrity hmm
and it's weird comparing the two because
I think of the two as being very I think
there are like youtubers that I think of
as whole yeah but it's but I recognize
that it's like not everyone will see
them as that words I think like so when
I say like celebrities I think it's like
more publicly recognized as a yeah but
it's interesting because
there are some people in traditional
work like you know TV or movies or
something that like at what point do
they become a celebrity verse like an
actor you know so it's like I think it's
like when something is successful enough
that they become more widely okay so so
so the and How I Met Your Mother
the the main character of that is he a
celebrity
[Music]
nobody likes Marshall and Barney are all
celebrities yeah but like like like or
even a smaller show you know so it's
like okay even in like you know so
there's like you know Brad Pitt you know
obviously a celebrity you know easily
yes celebrity chip and Joanna I'd say
they're celebrities they say they're
celebrities but like the lover listed
hosts are they celebrities I don't know
well again like that's kind of getting
into a different topic it is getting a
new difference yeah but it is
interesting like seeing that opinion and
so many people agreeing with it
mhmmm and I do think that there are
perks that you get from doing YouTube as
instead of you know doing celebrity jobs
I was gonna say acting but it's also
like musicians or whatever you know and
I think one of the biggest things is you
have a lot more independence yeah
control oh man and just like some of the
stories we've heard from people working
on TV and stuff like that we've talked
about this before well but like there's
so much less control and that sounds
very stressful to me we own all of our
content that's a huge thing that's
really interesting because no person
who's acted in the movie or like and
even people who sing the songs they
often don't own it's like the whole
thing with Taylor Swift and her like
originals getting sold off yeah yeah
yeah oh geez you just don't even own
your own music someone funds the
production and recording and
distribution and all of that and you
just don't own it and that that'd be
like mind-blowing to me you work on this
thing for so long and it's yours
you made it yet someone else owns it oh
yeah I
I think that there's a lot of perks to
doing YouTube as opposed to being a
traditional celebrity I mean neither of
us ever like wanted to be it's not like
we were both like oh well we want to be
actors but we can't do that so we'll be
on YouTube no we just want to work
together yeah we just work together it
was like a nice way to do it but and
it's more about like having the freedom
to work together which YouTube allows
and you know being a celebrity wouldn't
necessarily but also like having a
creative outlet and because we have more
control over what we're doing you know I
think you can still like be very
creative as a celebrity but for the type
of stuff that we want to do we might not
be able to do that if we were doing it
on a TV show yeah instead you know and
also we you know when we were going down
the TV route looking down that Avenue we
got a couple offers of like wood wood
wood Caitlin be open to doing something
just by yourself or would you be open to
doing something by just with you like no
that's the whole point of why we're
doing this so we can be together not so
we can like rise up and fame and
independent of each other that does not
appeal to terrible no okay so any other
reddit comments um that was the most
interesting one that I wanted to touch
on just not kind of like sentiment if
you're ready I'm ready to move on to the
game yeah
[Music]
so today's game we're gonna be playing
that like couples game where we ask
questions and we have answers written
down and you have to like make guess to
make guess where's our hard make guesses
so I have to guess yours and you have to
guess mine and we're gonna like tweak it
a little bit normally it's like we go
one at a time but both of us want to
answer all of these questions yeah so
we're gonna do that instead yeah so
questions will each guess the others
answer and reveal the correct answer all
right okay first question what was your
first impression when we first met okay
so I have to guess what you thought of
yes guess first she cute crush right my
first impressions is I first thought
that you were beautiful just because I
hadn't talked with you yet and then I
got the impression that you were really
nice and kind right away and then I
noticed that you were very intelligent
so those that was my initial impression
of you oh thank you you had like a three
phase I just wrote it down like my very
very first can you guess it tall no but
yes excitable no fun that's pretty close
one of the friendliest people I'd ever
met oh thank you okay it's true though
you're like I think especially because
because I met you like it's a very like
literally very beginning of college yeah
and I do think at college in the
beginning everyone's a little bit
friendlier yeah but you were like so
dang friendly
it helps me with my laptop and you
didn't even know me and host like oh my
god thank you
you know and like all this stuff and I
was such a shy person going into college
so funny hung out with shy people to the
beginning of college was so fun it was
like summer camp for six months or
something you know it was great it was
great
okay number two what is your favorite
material to work with in the shop I'm
gonna guess first resin yeah follow up
okay your second is walnut
no I wrote so residents over the same
thing resin is definitely my first one I
soap is like a current little obsession
you don't know how long it'll last but
like because we've been doing it it's
like it is so fun okay okay what do you
think my favorite material is I wanted
to see if you would guess properly for
me because I always thing like what do
you think like C and C or 3d printing
but that's but I guess like that's not
really material yeah that's true 3d
print like the plastic is the material
and see and see like the wood is like I
could have it could have been metal but
not really I mean no it's resin is resin
I just loved resin well it's actually we
were like I'm not sure this is gonna
come out before this thing but we're in
the middle of making resin knives oh boy
oh boy it's so pretty
yeah so pretty so what is your least
favorite video that we've made this was
this was hard for me what do you think
my guess was and why I went back and
forth a little bit it's it's do you
guess for me the robot no no okay
what is it let me guess okay and what do
you mean the robot the robot Mario 64's
was my least I don't know there's a lot
of aspects of it like performed I love
the video itself my favorite videos okay
ornaments the one where I was sick
yeah no but that was like a probably
close probably close second okay that's
in like my top 5 okay let's just say our
videos Miley's yours is how to be
original no yeah okay my least favorite
was the Caitlyn what the Caitlyn robot
arm Caitlyn robot arm yeah we made a
video of you on the robot arm the hand
of that
we published that video on our channel
and again the main reason why I chose it
as my least favorite is because I think
it could have been a lot better if we
had of like done a voiceover if we had
have done a little bit of an intro set
the stage got some like b-roll and we
could have turned it into something
interesting yeah dis for contacts
because you probably didn't watch this
one this is we were at Maker Faire and
there was like a giant robot hand that
you could like sit in a chair and
control the hand with your hand to pick
up a car and crush it and drop it and so
I did that and we weren't like planning
on making it a video but we had a few
friends like get footage for us and they
were like man this footage is really
cool and we edit it together for like a
social plan it was really cool really we
did I don't know what we were thinking I
don't know either
I don't might have picked that one yeah
if you had a thought of it I I didn't
even think of it because I like forgot
okay your least favorite is I don't know
I already I as one of my guesses well
how do we your original Oh and so it's
it's kind of a similar thing I like the
video this is a very old video and we
were like oh we're gonna be so meta it's
like a how-to like how to be original I
didn't choose that as my least favorite
because I liked what we were trying to
do even as we were filming it I was like
what do we sit down this a different way
the thing that I liked about it was a
collab with one of our friends Sean
Hogan who has a music channel and so we
sent him and this part I really like
yeah we like made a bunch of shot sounds
using stuff in the shop as we were
painting the color wall back yes we
could have just done it adds like a
normal tutorial we could have like used
his music and said like today we're
gonna be making a band and that's why we
didn't do that so we recorded sounds of
like the paintbrush dropping on the
board and like swiping the paint and
popping open the paint can and all these
various things and send it to him and he
made music from those sounds and it's so
cool and it's so good and he like uses
some of our footage but together a music
video in his video is awesome
then what we're doing for our part is we
were gonna make a video while we were
painting these backdrop pieces and use
his music make it artsy and make it
artsy and but we were like we can't
really do a how-to video on how to paint
backdrop uses because we were literally
just painting boards and so are like
that part will be obvious what if we
talk about like because the reason we
were doing the backdrops is to like
stand out stand out and like be unique
what if we like talked about that anyway
you're gonna do that again what would he
do I would have just like used the music
in a normal video that had nothing to do
with painting the backdrop at all I
would have just been like whatever our
next actual how-to video was and it
would have been would have been like by
the way if you like this music like our
friend Sean made it check it out his
channel we got the sounds while we were
painting our backdrop you can see the
new backdrop in this video for the first
time what I'm just like a shout out yeah
yeah just like a normal shout out yeah
we reached too far and we fell in our
faces slightly all righty this is this
fun game okay so what is your favorite
nickname for the supervisor dusty jube
it's like my current yeah the current
favorite because she has so many Nikki
one know who my current favorite that
I've been saying like a lot in the past
I don't know a month or so you can you
can it's like it keeps on evolving this
is like a new one I know but it's been
like my favorite I just keep calling or
Dukan and I can't stop so like jube is
one of her original nicknames and
there's been lots of like variations on
it like jus be Juba Jubair and we
started saying Hadouken won't tell them
the origin of jube oh I mean it was just
like they're it's such a weird origin
when my brother and I were younger and
we would go to my grandparents house
they have all the
Photowall of us like baby pictures and
there's one where I'm in a super super
fluffy dress and when my meet my brother
we would look at all the photos he would
always like pointed a photo and caption
it and he was like little and he did
this and every time he would see that
photo he would go I just like stuck with
me and I started calling her jube
because she was a little [ __ ] all
right yeah but now I've just been
calling her like it's like a shortened
version of Hadouken yeah it makes a lot
of sense yeah
so what do you think my favorite
nickname for her right now is is it
chunker no you know it's not already
said cuz you've said all my guesses yeah
your actual guess jube do the classic go
through a bear phase yeah you know but
jube is we we never call her mokey No
Mokey's her real name well mokey is her
real name I don't think we've ever we
haven't called her mokey in a long time
no but it's also like it's like veggie
but she's a veggie she is that jube okay
so Kailyn what is your favorite food
this is hard because we love food we
love food so much and what our favorite
food is kind of changes based on what
we've eaten recently I think doesn't
really change okay but like I just grow
I have two guesses for you okay tacos
pasta one of them is closed oh you have
a specific pasta no no no no it's
related to tacos kind of Oh breakfast
tacos no it's not a specific one but
it's related Mexican food in general
chips and salsa / guac what that's your
favorite food does that count as a food
that's more of an appetizer
I didn't say favorite meal
oh yeah thing like my other main thing
but you should have written that
said food it's much more open I was
thinking like sometimes I can get like
burnt out on tacos yeah but I never get
burnt out on like chips and salsa /
chips and guac oh yeah like I can have
that as a snack I can have that with a
Daniel yeah that's a really good thought
pasta was pretty close yeah generally
mm-hmm the word pasta yeah but I felt
like I'll get burnt out on pasta before
I'll get burnt out on just like just
chips and salsa I think like the most
dense like the the most frequently eaten
food that we have is probably pasta and
tacos yes I think I still think my
guests were pretty good gonna be bad
could you choose a pasta like of the
ones we make can I guess what it would
be if you had to pick a top if I had to
choose one forever
yes Bradley oh yes pasta with broccoli
actually vodka but it's actually wine
yeah it's like this is like this our
thing now if we ever do start the
evident Kaelyn Cooking Channel that
might have to be like our first one yeah
anyways so if we won the lottery what
would be the first thing that we buy do
you guess me first you guys me first I
think you would buy um like a place with
a new workshop yes yes a big house with
a workshop
yeah you got it mm-hmm I would guess the
exact same thing for you
place to start building our dream house
slash shop yeah cuz we love our house
but it's a little bit cramped as we are
right now this this room is a little bit
cramped
we would have our normal office and our
podcast and our gaming yeah so I think
we just need a little bit more space
that's that's the main thing okay so
what is the favorite what is your
favorite game we've played on the
podcast
singing games yes do you have a guess
which one cuz I do love the singing
singing game is general game / music
games I think that your favorite is
probably the humming first I wrote down
that the TV show games cuz I had a lot
of fun hunting oh yeah
doing like that which is where we it was
one brother not be monetized
yeah but then like the stress of it
getting D monetized and like playing
it's a little bit more stressful because
we tried playing a similar one where it
was like movie songs but yeah we
couldn't play the songs for too long
yeah um so the humming one was holding
this enjoyed my beautiful city make the
world go round
okay so what do you guys for me um I am
gonna guess I didn't actually think
about what yours would be I mean I want
to say the music ones because I love
those so much but I actually think yours
might be fail tank oh that's close the
fail tank is pretty good or is it the
defend yourself fan yourself is pretty
good both of those are right in my tops
it's a trick question it's a trick
answer what is it you're giving me a
look that doesn't help me this game this
game this game is my favorite I love it
for a lot of reasons one it allows us to
tell stories it allows us to go on
tangents but it also is gonna be really
easy to edit there's no pauses in it and
I feel like there's a lot of good things
about this game but we can prep ahead of
time and it didn't take that long to
prep there's a lot of aspects to this
game that are really sustainable cuz a
lot of games take a long time to prep
and then there's a lot of like pauses
while we pull stuff out there yeah and
then we sometimes put the scoreboard
above and everything and that takes a
wild at it so it's like this game is as
a high value per time input okay what
this is a really interesting one I'm
really curious about this what would be
the type of channel you at least want to
make for you I think it'd be reviewing
kids till is now I'm joking that was
this is hard to think of because a lot
of things where I was like oh I wouldn't
like making that and then I think like I
could really probably make it fun find a
way to make it so - it's like my first
instinct was like oh boy a review
channel I'm like you know
that we can make that hilarious we could
make that I could really enjoy that
where we just like buy toys will you cut
them in half we criticized that how
they're put together and their standards
of quality but I feel like we could make
that fun we can make a lot of things fun
yeah I wouldn't through the same thought
process and I was like well if I can
make that fun there's probably something
worse to do yeah so I think that here
you try to guess mine I would say like a
politics channel that would be horrible
I would hate that
hey I think that might be a better
answer than what I wrote down it that
was a tie for mine but I wrote down
something different okay I just don't
want to guess what I wrote where we have
to be fake where we have to be fake in
order to make the content and I know
that's kind of a vague cop-out answer
but like when if we like you know when
we're thinking of the TV show where
would I'd have to like pretend that I
can see a backyard without thinking of
renovating it or you would have to
pretend to love guards almost like like
if you if it wasn't a cell phone channel
but like if someone else owned it yeah
don't know who's telling us what to do
any channel or someone else is telling
us what to do and we'd have to fake it
that'd be my nightmare yeah I would not
like that yeah okay so for free for you
politics because we don't want to talk
about that hey that was like up there
but I didn't but I thought of something
else also kind of related waste cleanup
the waste cleanup channel where we have
to pick up poop do you want to hear mine
yeah
so a like corporate channel where we
were working for a company that doesn't
understand YouTube that would be
horrible and they were telling us what
to do yeah
because like that what I was thinking is
like you know because I used to work for
a big company and we had a YouTube
channel and it's like knowing what we
know about YouTube now but then like a
company being like make this thing and
make it like three facts about let's say
you worked for an industrial poop
cleaning company you have to make it
three facts about
industrial poop cleaning but like you
can't use the word poop and you can't
make any jokes and make any jokes no
popular it has to be approved by the
investors yeah go through all the
revisions and you have five music
changes and then everything like your
first rap you love the most and then
slowly over time to take away every
little bit of joy okay
I'm curious about what you what you
think I am and what I think you are okay
so if you were a drink what drink would
you be I think you would be tall glass
of Asti I think you would be a tall
glass of iced tea that's very close like
flavored iced tea with a splash of
lemonade baby yeah yeah be an Arnold
Palmer light on the lemonade very light
on the lemonade because you can drink it
anytime it's always refreshing it's
always amazing like if it's hot if it's
cold whatever it's always amazing it's
always refreshing and it's sweet and
it's awesome you're pretty close I mean
as a tea hot or iced because I pee wee
also basically just wrote down our
favorite drinks yeah Oh should we go
with alcoholic drinks but we just don't
drink alcoholic drinks anymore so yeah I
mean I guess if I wanted to like
personify a drink maybe maybe like hot
tea might if I was gonna have to pitch
my cheeks yes factly again no I'm just
thinking of like my favorite drink I
mean if I have it pick an alcoholic
drink it'd be my favorite drink which is
a Moscow Mule oh yeah it doesn't really
reflect me at all
good question Galen alright moving on
okay what is the weirdest thing you've
eaten this is this my turn weird skip
ahead of this if you are gross about
animal eating things cuz like there's no
plant thing that would be a weird thing
to eat really I bet there would be some
weird what if you would like eaten Venus
flytrap or something who would do that I
don't know but weird that would be weird
I wonder what the Venus flytrap venus
flytrap is kind of
an animal that's true or like what if
you would eaten like there's mussels in
there right because how does it cope and
enclose this mouth I don't know where
they chemicals or something plants move
other plants moves right follow the Sun
you're right how do how do sunflowers
follow the Sun do they have muscles in
their stalks no they don't yeah but or
like what if you had like um like tree
barks - that'd be weird that would be
weird
okay what do you think the weirdest
thing I've eaten is um so I know there's
a lot of things you don't like that you
don't normally eat but I don't know if
one of those things like might be
something that you tried once like some
sort of seafood related thing seafoods
growth I know yeah you don't like
seafood but I'm like would you consider
something you had tried and seafood
weird I don't know or is it like one of
the things that you've tried with me
like rock could be no I thought of rock
to be cuz that one is pretty well
something that I've eaten with you and
your family um what weirder stuff than
the raw meat is it raw meat
nope okay what's cooked seafood nope
because I have eaten some seafood with
your family but that wasn't that weird
wasn't weird no it was at a restaurant
we went out to was it some torta sort of
meat yes rabbit nope I I snuck the bill
Oh cow tongue yeah no I was picked on no
cow town cow dung Oh cow dung oh yeah I
tried to like pretend that it like I I
was adventurous in front of your family
I didn't dislike it but I wouldn't have
really jumped on that that's pretty
common it's kind of weird
that's kind of weird it's like it's like
the tongue don't think about it's a
muscle all meats possible yeah I don't
think about too much
okay so the weirdest thing that you've
eaten frog no balls no cat-cows thing
it's called like something oyster but
it's like a bull testicle yeah okay what
else is weird
this was with my family but I don't
think you were here was it is it seafood
related no is it animal release yes is
it a normal body part of an animal I
don't know what body part it was it was
probably normal Oh was it just a raw
thing
no it wasn't wrong oh it's just me and
all the people don't normally eat as far
as I know okay um doesn't walk not good
does it
Oh bear bear bear meat
I had bear meat once it was like well
wasn't that like that then invaded your
no it wasn't it wasn't the same bear
that was like tormenting my grandma's
house I don't know where they cut the
bear meat um but it was like - it wasn't
jerky but it was like dry enough it was
almost jerky it was really it is unusual
it is the weird unusual good I feel like
that's I feel like that's weirder than
Captain yeah just cuz cow tongue I've
seen at restaurants maybe those
restaurants that have bear not I don't
want now I don't want lunch
alright let's bring it over to the thing
of the week
alright guys my thing of the week is an
RGB mechanical keyboard oh my gosh I
love it it just cycles through the
rainbow in front of me and it just
brings me joy it is it's it's over there
it's I'm looking at it okay I'll get it
while you're talking about your thing of
the week but it's just so fun and we
might do a project with it in the future
yeah in the far future not anytime soon
yeah it's so cool though there's so many
different like color settings yeah you
can make it so like every button you
type changes color
oh but also it's like it's interesting
going into the world of mechanical
keyboards cuz there's like different
levels of clicks there's like like a
medium click a soft click a gradual
click a very clicky click how do you
like the click I like it when I'm typing
on it it is a little bit loud but you
can get a softer one if you if you want
to get a mechanical keyboard one day you
can't get silent mechanical keyboards
yeah but I kind of like the click in
some ways but also it's not the most
practical in any way for any situation
really I like the feel of it I like the
cup around like you know most keyboard
keys on keyboards nowadays are flat on
the mechanical keyboard it has a little
pocket for your fingers to rest him I'm
trying to soldier through this but um I
also like that there's all the different
varieties there's the 60% there's the 10
list there's the full one these are
different sizes of keyboard yeah I feel
good people weren't it's a fun rabbit
hole to fall into yeah um my thing the
week are you getting it my thing of the
week is and this isn't newly released
but we finally got a chance to watch it
you guys know that new savage builds
show it's Adam Savage's news show oh yes
I've been holding up the keyboard for
anyone watching it's so cool I bet so
the savage builds showed there was an
episode where he does like Mad Max cars
oh yeah couple friends and they like
deck them out and battle them at the end
and the friends that were on the show
are two of our friends it's Simone eh
and Laura comp both from both from
YouTube and it was so fun like watching
them all
three of them on the show like decking
out these cars and like it was such a
fun project but it was also just fun
like seeing these people we know yeah so
doing this like crazy project that would
be very hard to do in a YouTube space Oh
that'd be really hard like that the
budget the time the the filming that had
to be done because they had like
multiple drones that tons of cameras
yeah so so much and so this is cool like
getting to see people tackle this
project that would be really hard for
them to do otherwise and it was such a
fun video like you're like rooting for
oh my gosh Caitlin we should pitched
YouTube not that we have any ones
contact at YouTube but we should pitch
like a YouTube bread show where it's
like build off but it's like you know
that the old junkyard Wars and stuff
like yeah it's like junkyard Wars but
with youtubers YouTube makers and it's
just like a like it'd basically be that
episode but like but more and but also
it's like you know like going to a
junkyard and making a projectile weapon
you know and seeing who makes the best
projectile weapon is it going to be air
propelled is it going to be mechanical
is it going to be what what what that
would be as always we will have links to
our thing of the week's in the
description yep and I think that takes
us to the end of the podcast this was a
really really fun podcast that was a
good game good job picking it as your
favorite I think you came up with it
didn't you been on our list for a while
we had done it once before but we just
did it way less efficiently yeah then
this time we're learning we're leveling
up okay guys speaking of leveling up you
could level up the whole podcast by
leaving this a five star review on the
iTunes Store or I'm just sharing that
with a friend a colleague a family or
the family yeah I'll share it with the
whole family the gift of your family any
family to pick a family hi guys thanks
for joining us and we'll see you next
time
[Music]